affecting her husband she would never
try to make him look bad like maybe she
followed his leadership he said she
could do the coughing all right but she
certainly won't embarrass him in public
that would be crazy
in your personal opinion okay what
should you prefer what do you perform
more uh the BBC or uh Mr uh husband over
here
is this why you put us in two different
rooms
exactly we could just be truthful here
guys truthful okay
[Music]
um I did enjoy uh Jason
we all can do is interesting and fun but
[Music]
Jason over your husband
to one person for seven years
although Adam is very exciting We
Believe like a new experience is always
going to be a little more interesting
and different